[موسيقى]
حديث سير مروع يغير حياه شابه المقدسيه
حنين ابو غوش بلمح البصر ويبعدها على
عجلات متحركه بعد ان كانت فتاه حيويه
تتحرك كثيرا على حسب تعبيرها
اتت تتحول بحياتك كانت
التغيير العمله الكرسي يعني كان تغير 180
درجه كان عند حياتي هيك حيويه
تخيلت انه انا ممكن
اخسر الاشياء اللي او اكثر روتين الحقيقه
اللي انا كنت متعوده
قررت حنين ان تعيد جزء من حياتها السابقه
فتعلمت السياقه وبدات تعلم تخصص القانون
وتمارس حنينا اليوم عده العاب رياضيه
ونشاطات متعدده منها الغوص والكيك بوكسنج
والملاكمه
حياتي تحولت 180 درجه بعد نقطه كتير كتير
حساسه وهي النقطه الي انا كان في تصالح
بيني وبين الكرسي تقبلت الكرسي استوعبت
انه الكرسي وهي مش عدو بالعكس هو صاحبه هو
الاذان انا بستعملها عشان اقدر اتنقل
واروح واجي من المحل الثاني وهو الاذان
راح اقدر اكمل حياتي بست حنين من اهم
المتحدثات التحفيزيات من ذوي الاعاقه في
فلسطين وحولت الكرسي الى منبر كل واحد
فينا عنده تحديات بعيش كل يوم عنده تحديات
وبوجهها همم يمكن مرات احنا ما في ايدينا
شيء نعمله يعني ما في شيء بتعملي
بس اللي بتقدري تعملي انك تغير الطريقه
التفكيرك فيه
بعد ان قالت خسرت كل ما املك
تجاوزت حنين العجلات وتقول اليوم امشي الى
القمه دون قدمين تقودني روحي وقلبي
ومثابرتي الى حلمي لا نكون غاصي من القدس
صباح العربيه